we are still going here folks hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's
[Music]
kitchen we are back with part five of
our review of jaclyn hill's weight loss
series but it's healthier than me
ordering pizza
it's just like a doritos i'm most
excited for my badass a major cheat is
coming up i'm so bloated i haven't been
blurted for so long i just want my brain
to be normal
i'm literally sitting here eating pizza
this is i feel like the world's biggest
failure
someone come stop me
but first let me drop in here to tell
you about my sponsor thrive market so
thrive market is an online membership
based market that aims to make health
focus specialty products more affordable
and accessible to everyone basically you
do a guided shopping quiz to get a
personalized shopping list and product
recommendations specifically tailored to
your diet goals and household needs you
can also filter by different diet goals
like vegan or fair trade and shop for
your essential groceries beauty
supplements home goods and more they
work directly with every brand so you
get the best prices and if you find a
better price somewhere else they'll
match it i also love that they deliver
everything in carbon neutral packaging
from zero waste warehouses and shipping
is free on orders over 49
currently they only deliver to the
contiguous us so i always order as soon
as i go down to florida but they have
one month and 12 month options so you
can choose the membership model that
best fits your lifestyle the 12-month
membership is a really great deal
because it does come down to just five
dollars a month and if you join today
you'll get 40 off of your first order
and a free gift so definitely check out
my link in the description to sign up
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always please feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and of course don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
bell so that you never miss out on an
episode and if you're not following me
already on instagram and tick tock get
on it at abby's kitchen all right we are
in it for the long haul here folks so if
you've missed any of my previous reviews
on jaclyn's weight loss series you can
check out my most recent video right
here there is a lot of ground to cover
here today so we're going to be taking a
look at her november 8th video i don't
know if i can do this let's get into it
i'm pissed off i am i'm just pissed off
i'm hungry i've gained two pounds in the
last three days even though i feel like
i'm starving i've just been eating like
three perfect meals a day just like
vegetables a little fruit on the side
and a little protein and like no
snacking and i've gained two pounds and
i'm so angry i'm gonna go eat so much
pasta i am done i am so
done the fact that i have literally
barely eaten anything in the past couple
of days and i put on two pounds i'm done
i'm gonna go eat so much pasta i'm gonna
live
my
best i thought that i was kidding
okay that's cute i
really feel for jaclyn at this point i
really do as i mentioned in my review of
her previous video seeing weight
fluctuations of you know two to five
pounds could actually be completely
normal you know weight loss journeys
never look like a perfect straight line
down a graph so that really isn't
necessarily concerning to a professional
like me now what is concerning is
jaclyn's reaction to the number going up
on the scale so we are seeing the
pendulum swing from what she briefly
describes as starving by subsisting off
of lots of vegetables and protein to
living her best and eating all the
things and while i am hearing her claim
this journey is about self-care i feel
that this behavior seems like a very far
cry from caring now research suggests
that frequent self-weighing like this
can negatively impact mood and
self-esteem particularly for folks who
struggle with disordered eating had
jaclyn made a point to not weigh herself
along this journey i would bet that she
would have continued to feel motivated
to eat in a more balanced satisfying way
she would have been able to use that
mental space for other important goals
like her jewelry launch and honestly
her weight probably would have continued
to trend downward over time but the
stress from yo-yo dieting is emotionally
not motivating and is also physically
unsupportive because it's likely causing
some hormonal shifts like an uptick in
cortisol levels i'm just so frustrated
because i put on two pounds and i'm just
sitting there even though i am doing
everything right and tonight is my
halloween party and yeah i could totally
make like better decisions and be like
i'm not gonna drink tonight or like i'm
you know gonna have a salad no but
that's just not the case i'm gonna enjoy
like i'm gonna relax i'm gonna have a
good time because i'm so hungry you guys
like when i was losing the most weight a
couple of weeks ago i felt like my
hunger level was so low and it was like
really easy not to snack it was really
easy to make good choices i'm like
starving 24 7. like i will eat an entire
meal and i'll be why am i so hungry so
what is going on well i mean there's
absolutely no way for me to know for
sure but i can tell you a few potential
theories one from what i've seen
jaclyn's diet is pretty low carb so a
lot of that initial weight loss was
probably a lot of water weight which can
be very motivating at first but has to
eventually slow down
two
earlier on in the journey she was able
to drop weight really fast and seemingly
kind of like outsmart her hunger but at
this point it's almost like her body is
freaking out
realizing that it's been duped like it's
screaming to be re-fed to help bring her
back to her set point where her weight
is just more comfortable sitting what
happens in this scenario is that leptin
satiety hormone levels tank the ghrelin
hunger hormone and cortisol levels rise
and this trifecta makes it a lot harder
to lose weight or suppress one's
appetite finally there's also the
mindset around the scale at play as
we've already discussed that all or
nothing mindset always sets us up for a
binge or we can just throw all those
theories aside in the event that maybe
she's gonna get her period because we
know that weight gain is very common
when you're going to get your period we
know that hunger tends to increase when
we're getting our period these things
are normal and i actually have a whole
video on what to eat at different points
in your cycle you can watch right here
those are terrible i see we've made it
to the other end of the spectrum eating
mcdonald's breakfast this isn't even
worth the cheap i'm too lazy
this is what we often call the last
supper mentality you know i already
ruined my diet so i might as well just
go all in stop it this is a running
theme with jacqueline and really not
uncommon with extremely restrictive
diets having said that i want to just
reassure jaclyn and also everyone else
that a mickey d's breakfast doesn't need
to represent the other end of the
spectrum as jordan said assumingly
juxtaposing it against her health food
kick i mean in my professional opinion
the egg wrap and pancake combo may
actually be a pretty good hangover cure
so research suggests that the cysteine
in eggs helps to remove the acetaldehyde
buildup from the body after a long night
of drinking
alcohol also lowers blood sugar levels
and leads to nausea and fatigue so the
carbs from the pancakes and the wrap may
also help to provide a little quick
energy boost that we really need plus
we've got some protein and fat going on
to help slow that blood sugar response
down so if we pair that with like a big
bottle of water and maybe a piece of
fruit for some fiber and lots of rest i
think she made a fine post drinking
choice hernips so he just sliced up
turnips and was putting some like oils
and herbs on them and baking them for 15
minutes but i personally have been
craving cheese pizza so bad so instead
of ordering pizza i made this for myself
it's literally a low calorie tortilla
it's like one of those like 80 calorie
tortillas and then i put mozzarella on
it and i put turkey pepperoni but i know
it's still not healthy but it's
healthier than me ordering pizza okay i
love the ease of this diy pizza and i
think it's great that rather than
suppressing her craving she's finding a
way to satisfy it in a way that works
for her however i do want to just point
out that i don't know the calories in
this homemade pizza are not really that
far off from having a slice of regular
thin crust pizza and i'm not pointing
this out to encourage her to put the diy
pizza on the off limits list but rather
just to reassure everyone that real
delivery pizza is also no big deal
pizza time in fact if you want to learn
how to turn it into a super saturating
hunger crushing combo you can check out
my video right here the turnip chips
sucked so that was a fail so instead i'm
eating seaweed
it's just like a dorito okay so not all
healthy swaps can be winners and i'm not
sure i agree that seaweed is just like a
dorito um i think she was being
sarcastic but it does look like she
genuinely likes it which is what we love
to see seaweed is also low in calories
and is a great source of iodine so it's
a great snack if you like that umami
flavor and crunch on top of everything
of course i think i'm most excited for
my badass a major cheat is coming up
[Applause]
i'm so bloated i haven't been this
bloated in so long so much cheese
carb don't regret eating it because it's
literally the best food i definitely ate
too much and man it's like when you're
eating cleaner and then you eat stuff
like that it just like affects you so
heavy it's like you love food but then
you can't even enjoy it when you eat
like that i'm not eating for a week this
scene says a lot to me i mean this is
exactly the outcome that i would expect
when you're living the kind of clean
eats to cheat day life if you know that
you're gonna have to restrict again
tomorrow never mind to not eat for a
week as she sarcastically suggested of
course you're going to overeat this is
survival like feast and famine the last
supper now she mentioned not being able
to enjoy these foods that she loves and
yeah when the outcome is feeling sick
and super bloated i get it it is not
even enjoyable at the end nor i would
say it's the experience of extreme
restriction so the solution to me is
quite clear we need a gentler approach
one that allows her to have a taco and
not see it as the end of the world now
if we were to pair a couple tacos let's
say with a salad to give us a hunger
crushing combo we would get our fun food
fix while also feeling satisfied and
comfortable
and we could move on to the next day
without tightening the reins even more
this cycle has to end i'm really
struggling you guys i'm struggling with
anxiety and depression so bad it's so
hard
looking at my house i'm like look at my
beautiful home like look at all the
things that i have i just want my brain
to be normal i can identify so
much with this
like i feel like she just took a quote
from my own therapy session because i
have the same realization every single
day and i know a lot of you guys
watching jacqueline or even me like you
assume we might have it all together but
the reality is we all have a cross to
bear and also it's never about the food
it's never just about the food so i
finally have decided that it's time that
i get help so i actually have my first
therapy session tomorrow oh
which is amazing i'm grateful i'm able
to do this but i'm also like can't help
it i always feel like i'm broken when i
have to go to therapy hey jacqueline's
so [ __ ] up beauty therapy again it's
so silly it's so stupid okay so i was
just going to say that i hope she can
reach out for professional support and i
really want to applaud jacqueline for
taking such a courageous and important
step i'm really really confident that a
professional can help jacqueline get to
the root of her eating patterns and
develop some better coping mechanisms to
help her manage her anxiety and no
jaclyn you are not broken for needing
therapy
i'm so mad at society so sorry that
society has made you feel that way or
anyone else feel that way like i
honestly think that we all need therapy
especially after the past year when a
lot of our traditional supports and
communication systems were just taken
away like i think we can all agree here
that it has not been easy for anyone uh
yesterday i ate from a food truck and
then last night i said and i had a huge
bowl of macaroni and cheese and two hot
dogs literally what made me fat in the
first place is what put fat on my body
yes
so much better than to go the second
that i go live and i'm able to breathe
i'm eating all of this yeah i'm gonna
eat pizza for the first time in a really
long time i'm gonna eat whatever the
hell i want i am so upset because it's
just very easy for me to be like wow
great another fail jaclyn way to go
i really feel badly for jaclyn i mean i
feel i feel my own anxiety levels going
up just thinking about her launch right
now as a fellow content creator and i
want to acknowledge that leaning on food
for comfort during stressful times is
totally
normal in fact there's actually a
scientific reason why we often crave
carbs when we're stressed since carbs
boost our happy neurotransmitter
serotonin levels in the brain but even
though there's no denying that food
plays a role in our mood we need to find
other coping tools in our toolbox i'm
literally sitting here eating pizza this
is i feel like the world's biggest
failure because i feel like i'm just
kind of right back to the past and the
sense of my face is like getting bigger
again i'm eating foods that cause
inflammation i am so stressed out i just
want comfort food like i'm not eating a
lot like i'm only eating like twice a
day right now because i go from being so
stressed that i can't eat too all of a
sudden when i am hungry all i want is
carbs all i want is cheese and pizza so
it's one thing to give yourself
permission to eat food which i fully
support but pairing that with guilt and
shame will only kick the emotional
roller coaster into high gear this
sounds like a really stressful time for
jaclyn and maybe it's a time that we
actually need to be focusing on exercise
and compassion
rather than calling ourselves a failure
or loser i think it's really hard to be
a creator and share all of these
vulnerable moments with fans on the
internet but i also think that this
content and looking at it and reviewing
it objectively might be a really great
opportunity for jacqueline like if it
were a best friend saying all these
things what would you tell her how would
you convince her that she's not a
failure that she's not a loser and that
eating the pizza and resting is maybe
the best thing that she can be doing for
herself right now as for the scenario of
losing her appetite only then to kind of
later overeat comfort foods this is not
an uncommon pattern if this sounds like
you i recommend setting alarms for
yourself every few hours to sit down for
a meal or snack even if nothing sounds
particularly good to you pre-plan out
some simple tolerable options that can
at least fuel your body and mind this at
least helps deal with the physical
hunger piece which typically makes the
psychological hunger less noisy and
desperate it also helps prevent those
spikes in cortisol which can actually
just perpetuate those negative emotions
instead had a panic attack i'm trying
not to think about it too much and like
get myself all worked out i know it's
just a website issue but now that i had
a website issue people are just like
waiting to see me fail and it's oh
people just want to cancel me so hard
and it sucks last night for dinner i had
two pieces of pizza and a chicken wing
and a lot of ranch when you were
stressed out and going through things
how come it is so easy to make the worst
food decisions like haven't worked out
haven't been getting good sleep haven't
been hydrating myself and i've literally
just eaten whatever is around that's
that also i'm about to eat pasta and i
had a piece of pizza
someone come stop me i said it at the
start of jaclyn's journey and i will say
it again but jaclyn could really benefit
from a psychologist and dietitian team i
mean the therapy can help address using
food as a coping mechanism as well as
her anxiety in general and a dietitian
could help jacqueline see how her
restriction is actually likely fueling
her anxiety and also her overeating this
is a common but ineffective cycle that
just perpetuates emotional and physical
dysregulation so where does jacqueline
go from here well while jaclyn is not my
client what i would suggest for folks
struggling with a similar pattern is to
put any food or diet manipulation on the
back burner like shift the journey to
one of improving mental health and
self-care not for improving her diet and
definitely not for losing weight
fresh start new goal as for specific
nutrition advice i actually think in a
case like this i would say it's not even
worth talking about nutrition yet we
have to stop trying to make meals
perfect because it makes it hard not to
have negative emotions about ourselves
when they're not perfect we need to
start with a blank slate that isn't
riddled with moralized beliefs about
food and our body in order to get to a
place where we can have a salad and not
feel deprived or we can have you know a
few slices of pizza and not feel like
we're the world's worst person my hope
for jacqueline if she does watch my
videos is that she's maybe able to see
some patterns emerge that weighing
herself too regularly and restricting
down to two meals a day is not netting
out to a positive health experience but
i'm sending jaclyn lots of healing
therapy vibes and i really hope that
moving forward she can prioritize
self-care over self-control and on that
note that is all that i have for you
guys today and thank you again to thrive
market for sponsoring don't forget to
check out my link below to get 40 off of
your first order and a free gift if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
your thoughts and what you'd like to see
me cover next subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]